we're back with more of Disney's saddest
deleted scenes that will undoubtedly
have you reaching for your Kleenex box
wait until you hear about the messed up
original ending of The Hunchback of
Notre Dame and how they changed it to a
happier one instead here is part two of
Disney's saddest deleted scenes you
never knew about Bambi Bambi is the
story about the adventures of a young
fawn and his forest creature friends
they giggle and prance through the woods
and everything is fun and happy until
they completely rip our hearts out how
do they do this by taking Bambi's
mother's life who can forget the
horrible sound of that hunters gunshot
echoing through the trees but this story
of a Disney character losing a parent is
anything but new in fact it's kind of
waltz theme so why was this one so
haunting maybe it's because we never
actually see Bambi's mother's body and
for Bambi's naive optimism that they
both made it is just so devastating but
the scene could have been a lot worse
the original version of that scene was
even more gruesome and horrifying in the
deleted scene Bambi didn't just run away
while only hearing that fateful gunshot
the scene showed Bambi finding his
mother's impression in the snow then he
sees a hunter dragging away his mother's
lifeless body now that would have ruined
countless childhoods all across the
country at least the final scene allowed
kids to come to terms with bandy losing
his mother in their own time The Lion
King Disney's The Lion King is an
animated classic that has it all it's
got adorable lion cubs singing upbeat
colorful songs about being King and it's
got the most catchy song since it's a
small world we're talking about
Hakuna Matata of course but you might be
surprised to find out that this
fun-filled film almost had a forced
marriage to eight in this deleted scene
scar is feeling dissatisfied he has a
conversation with Zazu about what's
missing from his life scar asks what
Mufasa had that he doesn't have
Zazu lists off a variety of things such
as adoring subjects the respect of his
species a loving family and a devoted
Queen scar here's that last one and
decides that he needs to marry a lioness
and make her his queen
just then Nala walks in talk about
rotten timing
skaara takes a creepy turn during his
interaction with Anala he tries to
convince her to marry him and let's just
say she's not on boards so he tries to
force her to marry him he threatens her
with banishment if she does not agree
this leads her to risk her life
wandering through the jungle to look for
help
good call on deleting that scene Disney
the many endings of Charles Muntz in
Disney's up filmmakers revealed that
they had to rewrite the ending of
Disney's up several times it was a
struggle to figure out a way to defeat
the villain Charles Muntz they wrote
several versions of the scene before
landing on the final version at first
they were going to have Charles meet his
demise by chasing Kevin the bird to this
rock labyrinth in this version Muntz
follows kevin into the maze and can't
find his way out so he has just left to
wander forever in this endless labyrinth
but they felt that took too much focus
away from Carl and Russell then they
were going to have months run after
Kevin into Carl's house on top of the
blimp the dogs are going to run in after
him causing the house to slip off the
blimp Muntz would then fall with the
house to his doom that's not the best
for a number of reasons number one the
house represented Carl's wife and they
didn't want months to go out with Ellie
like that
and number two that ending would have
resulted in a whole lot of deceased
canines they finally went with months
getting caught in the balloon strings
and falling with the balloons good call
guys Robin Hood if you're a fan of
Disney's 1973 classic Robin Hood you may
be interested to know about this
alternate ending in this version Robin
gets wounded when he's escaping from the
burning castle one of the arrows being
shot at him actually connects when he's
in the water
Robin is rescued by Little John and
taken to the church there Maid Marian
and little sister treat Robins wounds
and take care of him Prince John and Sir
hiss follow Robin seeing that little
John left the church they believe him to
be vulnerable Prince John comes at Robin
with a dagger with the intention of
putting Robin out of his misery
but Maid Marian stands up to Prince John
she tells him not to come any closer
just before King Richard shows up King
Richard makes everything all right again
and all is well the King Knights Robin
Hood as
Robin of Loxley then he orders Friar
Tuck to marry Robin and Maid Marian
which he does that's a very different
ending than what was shown during the
film's final scenes then Robin and Maid
Marian ride away in the carriage just
like the final ending of the movie
apparently they took out the other stuff
because they decided it was too dark for
the younger audience Tarzan
no matter which way you look at it that
leopard in Tarzan is just mean seriously
what is up with his hunger for helpless
bees in the opening of the movie we see
baby Tarzan and his parents surviving a
shipwreck on their way to Africa they
wash up on shore and immediately build a
pretty fancy treehouse then the film
cuts to Kerchak and kala with their
little one
then one night Kerchak and khalas baby
gets up to chase a frog away from the
safety of his parents mean old sabor
takes the opportunity to turn the little
guy into a late-night snack they are
devastated but kala later finds baby
Tarzan in the abandoned tree house after
sabor attacked and took his parents
while there's evidence that sabor ate
Tarzan's parents we don't see the attack
we only see some paw prints and blood
marks but in the alternate opening they
actually did show the attack it's a
series of storyboard pieces shown on the
special features the scene has a pretty
hardcore ending it shows Tarzan's dad's
body being dragged off by saver
that scene would have given kids
nightmares for weeks Alice in Wonderland
there's a rather disturbing scene in
Disney's 1951 classic Alice in
Wonderland luckily it never made it into
the movie after we tell you about it
you'll see why it starts with the
fish-footman arriving at the Duchess's
house with an invitation from the Queen
to play croquet
after the footman shouts across the moat
an accordion type bridge suddenly shoots
across the water the Duchess's Frog
footman lazily falls out as the footman
discussed the invitation
Alice sneaks onto the bridge and enters
the home of the Duchess when Alice
enters the smoky kitchen she sees an
angry cook making pepper soup it's total
chaos as the Duchess is trying
desperately to calm her ugly sneezing
and crying baby Alice asks the Duchess
to do something to quiet the baby the
Duchess grabs a cork from a bottle and
sit into the mouth of the child stopping
the noise the Duchess violently rocks
the baby and sings a song about beating
him when he sneezes the Duchess is
pulling the cork in and out of the
screaming baby's mouth which causes the
cook to lose her temper the cook begins
hurling pots and pans at the baby so
Alice rescues the baby and runs away
but the child later turns into a pig and
runs off yeah we can see why that one
didn't make the final cut lilo and
stitch when lilo and Stitch came out in
theaters in 2002 the country was still
recovering from the attacks on the World
Trade Center from 2001 this was supposed
to be the feel-good movie audiences
needed but it had a major problem there
was an action sequence at the end of the
film that would have triggered a
traumatized nation they had to make a
pretty big change to the ending before
they released it originally lilo and
Stitch had an action-packed ending where
stitch hijacked a commercial airplane to
rescue lilo stitch in his house take
over a 747 filled with scared passengers
then they go on a high-speed chase
dipping through and clipping skyscrapers
and coming pretty close to pedestrians
on the ground it's pretty triggering to
watch obviously the filmmakers couldn't
show that ending after what the country
had just been through on 9/11 so they
rewrote it in the final release version
Stitch takes over a red white and blue
spaceship and instead of flying through
the city the animators had it take place
over Hawaii's mountains and volcano
landscapes this made for a much more
pleasant movie going experience for
American audiences it was definitely the
right call Who Framed Roger Rabbit Who
Framed Roger Rabbit is Disney's tribute
to old film noir classics but with
animated and live-action characters
interacting it's full of clever dialogue
silly songs funny jokes and of course a
big mystery to solve but there was one
very sad scene that didn't make it to
the final movie apparently because of
legal reasons along with the complexity
of the animation required this scene was
deleted from the script but a fan dug up
some storyboard art on this deleted
scene which displayed Marvin acnes
funeral the sequence starts with Eddie
arriving at the funeral
and making his way through a long column
of cars in the upper right hand corner
of the drawing you see a note that reads
toons unload casket all the cartoon
characters are sad and crying as the
toons carry Marvin Acme's casket goofy
makes a joke about how tough it is being
a pallbearer
then Popeye cracks a joke asking why
they're bearing Paul and that he thought
they were burying Acme Pluto doesn't
like this disrespectful comment so they
get into a little graveside brawl this
leaves you of somebody Sam as the only
toon left holding acnes casket he
struggles to hold it up before deciding
to just toss it into the open grave site
then a weepy foghorn leghorn
begins the ceremony that's a pretty sad
scene for a silly tuned movie Hunchback
of Notre Dame nobody wants to be cooped
up here forever the Disney movie The
Hunchback of Notre Dame was adapted from
the novel which was much darker than the
film they had to make some major
adjustments to the story to cater to the
younger audience even with the changes
the film is still pretty dark in the
movie adaptation Quasimodo rescues
Esmeralda from being burned at the stake
by Frollo he takes her to the safety of
the bell tower
Frollo falls to his doom from the
cathedral balcony the Quasimodo
Esmeralda and Phoebus survived Quasimodo
unites Esmeralda and Phoebus then he
walks down the steps of the cathedral
and his embrace Fred the public happy
endings the book however was much more
depressing in the book Frollo hands
Esmeralda over to the authorities
accusing her of a crime that he actually
committed she's sentenced to a public
hanging and Quasimodo pushes Frollo off
the balcony in a fit of rage
then in an act of deep grief at losing
Esmeralda Quasimodo stays with her body
in the grave and starves about eighteen
months later the tomb is opened and they
find the bodies of Esmeralda and
Quasimodo they try to separate them but
their bodies just turned to dust and
crumble away that's a big old drag of an
ending for a Disney film it's no wonder
they changed it to a more upbeat happy
ending instead which still he did scene
did you think was the saddest let us
know in the comments give this video a
big thumbs up if you love
Disney movies be sure to subscribe to
the themes and while you're at it hit
that notification bell thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]